[Laughter]
[Music]
magic is all around us but you'll never
see it if you don't go out and look
[Music]
oh why are the river cystical creatures
No Bottle has seen one for centuries
do you have a first name
hi Gizmo I'm Sam
this species is wildly dangerous
Rock
never get them wet
no bright light
and never feed them after midnight
our only concern should be the bulk
right falling into the wrong hands
[Music]
who's that
the wrong hands where is mine Mogwai
these creatures may prove useful in my
Endeavors first Shanghai
then the world
if we don't save Gizmo who will
we need to return Gizmo to his home to
save Humanity
never catch Sam we are dealing with
creatures to Arms chaos I simply need to
channel their destructive energy
the only know how to do this if we don't
end it here
the world becomes a ghost City
[Music]
how many monsters did you slay today huh
same as always zero
foreign